South Korea's fusion of R&B pop and rap
is known by a different name
k-pop there are millions in the wannabes
stars and a lucky few get their shot at
kpop greatness hi my name is Marshall
and I am a singer-songwriter based in
South Korea I grew up right next to
Disneyland my parents would always take
me to this dancing water show that they
had I remember all the dancing lights
and the colors and the water that would
move to the music all of my favorite
Disney songs which by the way my
favorite was the Little Mermaid I knew
every song by heart
I wanted it to be Ariel and my parents
were probably sick and tired of it
it wasn't really until high school that
I would say that I kind of blossomed
I discovered show choir and that kind of
became kind of like a training ground
that's where I got my first solo that's
where I found my first friends that's
where I discovered my love of music my
dream was to be a singer I mean I I
would see people like Mariah Carey or
Destiny's Child and see them perform and
be like I want to do that
[Music]
my family and I would attend church
every Sunday
I was involved in there like praise and
a worship band I went on mission trips I
mean I did pretty much everything there
was to do in the Evangelic all Christian
culture at the time most of it was
positive I definitely only showed a part
of myself and wasn't able to reveal
certain parts of me that were essential
to who I was as a person I think when I
came out to my parents I don't think
they knew what exactly to do it the
information I don't think they even know
that afternoon to be honest with you I
don't think they know what LGBTQ all
means they assumed certain things about
it and I had to do a lot of explaining
and you know it's still a process they
haven't accepted it in any terms these
days we don't really talk about it we
just kind of avoid the conversation like
it's cool like it's fine we still see
each other there's a lot of other things
to talk about I try to be as respectful
of their space as they are you know I
give them credit for at least listening
to me as they grow older I just realized
that we don't have too much time in that
every every moment spent with them as is
precious
[Music]
I moved to Korea five years ago to
pursue my dream career I had a very very
small understanding of Korea
[Music]
I think what we put out there really
doesn't affect people I obviously say
that from experience because I've been
so affected by music as well as certain
songs that have really spoken to to me
giving me comfort letting me know that
I'm not alone I want to say that I feel
the most life when I'm either in the
recording studio working on music or
when I'm on stage just the energy and
the adrenaline that you get from all
those people chanting or screaming that
energy is just I can't even put into
words it's an indescribable feeling but
I think it's better than I think it's
better than sex to be honest with you
I'm not who I was you know last year or
three years ago or five years ago or ten
years ago I'm still Marshall but I'm a
different kind of Marshall for some
reason I happen to be where I am today
and I don't know why I am where I am
today but by god I'm going to take this
opportunity and use it for good for
positivity as much as I possibly can to
all of you who are figuring things out
enjoy every moment of your journey
leading up to reaching your goals or
reaching your dreams I don't know if
I'll reach my goals or reach my
accomplishments or reach all of my
dreams
at a certain age but that's okay because
I feel like I'm already winning by being
present in the moment and learning from
all of these other experiences in
reaching that goal or dream
[Music]
[Music]